ce bâtiment clair lumineux l'on fabrique
à d'abord des chaussures puis des
caméras les caméras beaulieu utilisé par
les cinéastes du monde entier et enfin
les voitures matra le tout étant donc
mais d'une romorantin loir-et-cher
france signe des temps c'est désormais
un musée mais quel musée le musée matra
consacré à l'histoire glorieuse de cette
marque de voiture mais voilà
qu'aujourd'hui les bagnoles sont certes
un peu pour laisser de la place à ce que
l'industrie motocycliste a accouché de
plus poétique
les motos anglaises c'est arrivé un
petit peu par dix armand au début on
devrait héberger trois ou quatre motos
pour l'hiver et puis de 4 s'est passé à
6 10 et puis maintenant on arrive à 40
ah bon mais viennent d'où ces motos
elles viennent de la région du coin des
particuliers qui les prêtent
gracieusement jusqu'à la mi mars
le premier modèle exposé date de 1912
c'est une singer de cinq centimètres
cubes le seul exemplaire connu
aujourd'hui tout simplement à côté
d'autres raretés dont 7
delos est les dix modèles de 220 cm cube
construite en 1914 est destiné par son
cadre ouvert aux dames et aux
ecclésiastiques pourtant soutane c'est
après la deuxième guerre mondiale que la
production anglaise domina le marché
mondial avec des marques d'un
classicisme absolu triomphe et c'est
bonneville norton et sa commande ofas
bac mais aussi des extravagances
magnifique comme cette indian vélo de
1971 à scrambler anglo american ou
italiens de 5 centimètres cubes aux
teintes pastel ou sept love in mille
âmes x motocyclistes construite par des
privés à partir d'une mécanique tirer
des motos vincent et d'une partie cycle
de norton modèle mix it est ce possible
200 kilomètres heure ce foisonnement des
années 60 sont british fut le bouquet
final de la domination anglaise
c'est l'histoire de cet empire
motocyclistes britannique qui reste à
voir au musée matra jusqu'au 17 mars